i see the pigs and i'm thinking oh crap
i'm just praying at this point that
nothing fails
i'm confident that i made a good blade
this is gonna be spectacular
the scottish
claymore the claymore was used by
scottish mercenaries in battle from the
15th to 17th century
the weapon usually 55 inches in length
would have to be held with both hands
and swordsmen were unable to carry a
shield symbolizing fearlessness on the
battlefield
the klansmen would swing the sword in
figure eight movements
decapitating and dismembering
adversaries
legend has it that scottish knight
william wallace used to claymore in the
war for scottish independence this epic
weapon has been immortalized in the
classic movie braveheart
bladesmiths this is the kill test the
term claymore in gaelic means great
sword to see how lethal your weapon is
and to test its functionality according
to its historic design i will deliver
two killing blows on this animal carcass
scott you're up you ready i'm ready
let's do it
i see the pigs and i'm thinking oh crap
i've cut tests against pigs and they
don't cut very easily at all
oh
the moment doug hits the pig and i hear
that thud
i'm like crap
uh scott we have a little problem here
the hardness of your blade
is a little bit on the
flexible side it did not even cut the
carcass
so that brings into question also
the sharpness of your edge
i think and we're pretty much done
congratulations
it
will not kill
this is a failure
jonathan you're up are you ready
absolutely i'm confident that i made a
good blade
the blade is hard and it's ready to cut
this is gonna be spectacular
oh boy
[Music]
jonathan we have a major blade
malfunction
it did initially cut through but then it
probably hit the spine
it just exploded
i'm not completely confident that i'm
going to come out with the wind here but
my blade cuts
and that's more than scots
jonathan your blade suffered
catastrophic failure for safety reasons
we can no longer continue testing on
your blade
since both weapons have suffered
malfunctions
dave will now decide on the best course
of action to move forward with the
competition
dave
in the viking sagas swords broke in the
song of roland's swords broke but bent
swords can be straightened
so we'd like to give you an opportunity
scott to straighten that weapon so we
can take it forward into a sharpness
test to help us determine our winner
so scott why don't you take a moment and
straighten your weapon okay
that's as straight as it's gonna get
now not only was the claymore a
battlefield intimidator but it was also
a scottish symbol for physical prowess
and strength so what i'm going to do to
test the edge of your blade is i am
going to cut into this piece of sheet
steel
so scott are you ready let's do it
i've got a 50 50 shot that it's gonna do
well you know i just want to see what
happens
i am desperate to win this ten thousand
dollars on the line here
i don't even want to watch
[Music]
[Music]
well scott
there's actually still an edge here
we can see what it did to the steel
should have the pig made out of steel it
probably would have cut better
all in all well done thank you
overall i'm pleased this was the first
time i've ever made a blade of this size
of this complexity
gentlemen this by far was our most
difficult challenge to date
congratulations you both delivered
your scottish claymores
but there can only be one champion
scott
congratulations you are the forged and
fire champion thank you
thanks jonathan unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut
jonathan the design of your blade was
really going in the right direction
basically once that blade snapped it
just wasn't anything else we could do to
test that blade so that's why we're
letting you go jonathan please surrender
your weapon
it's great
thank you sir
i'll be back
absolutely proud of myself with every
failure there's a great lesson learned
and i think i'm moving forward from here
scott congratulations you are the force
to fire champion and you'll be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
[Applause]
i've never won anything in my life this
is the first time i've ever won anything
you try your best and you learn from it
and then you do it again until you
perfect it
i mean even though the sword didn't do
what i wanted it's still okay i won
i'm certainly going to be buying drinks
tonight
[Music]
the spanish nabaja
rising to popularity in the 1600s the
spanish navajo was a deadly folding
weapon common in duels and street brawls
this blade could be folded into the
handle and locked in place making it
easy to conceal
it featured a locking ratchet mechanism
which kept the blade in place
the ratchet sound of the navajo opening
was also used to intimidate foes wielded
with the blade up a strike from the
navajo was difficult to parry and wounds
were often fatal the bajas were often
inscribed with pithy phrases in spanish
boasting about the deadliness of the
blade
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do all take your spanish
zavaja then deliver killing blows on
this deer carcass
matthew you're up first you ready oh
yeah
okay matthew nice and solid work right
here but i'm still recovering from an
injury so please welcome anthony palmer
anthony is one of the chief instructors
of mercade kali today he will have the
pleasure of wielding
your spanish nobody
my biggest concern going into testing is
the sharpness of my blade
[Music]
your blade is beautiful and it's also
solid in its feel it lacerates easily
you can see it chopped right through the
spine now one of the pieces here came
flying out during the test
but in terms of the sharpness and the
wieldability of your blade
it will kill
oh yeah okay wade it's your turn you
ready
you bet
please wait i can hear the mechanism
working in there
the thud of that deer carcass hitting
the floor is absolutely the sound of ten
thousand dollars
i feel like i'm ahead that's where i
want to be i want to win it
all right wade your blade is sharp thank
you the one issue is it's kind of
rickety here even while it was being
wielded but despite being riggedy it's
deadly
and it will kill
thank you next stop is a strength test
ben
to test the strength and durability of
your edge as well as the overall
construction i'm gonna smash into this
bamboo with your spanish navajos matthew
you're up first are you ready oh yeah
i'm looking at wade like he is one up on
me his blade might wiggle a little bit
but it just cut that deer in half i have
to out perform him on this strength test
if i'm gonna win this competition
[Music]
well matthew this thing's won a hell of
a chopper held together beautifully
there was slight glinting that happened
up here near the tip but it's pretty
darn sharp
very well done thank you
wade you're up next you ready
yeah
i'm ahead he's ahead i'm a head he's
ahead we've been this way the whole time
it's a battle i want to win it
no it's broken
well wade we have a problem
on about the third strike things started
to get kind of loose and that torquing
and the stress
made your scales pop off
the only thing holding the cutting end
to the handle end are these thin brass
sheets and i don't have confidence in
their strength this blade has lost its
structural integrity it's no longer safe
to test
wade due to the catastrophic failure of
the structural integrity of your weapon
we cannot continue testing that blade so
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
i thought i could beat down a door with
that thing but you know apparently you
can't i should have put more weight in
the liner just to make the whole handle
section much more strong
matthew congratulations you are the
force and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job
i just won forage and fire and i am so
excited
being here as a winner means a lot to me
i've had so much support throughout my
life to do what i'm passionate about and
my passion has proven to be what i
should be doing i'm supposed to be a
metal worker stay with it don't stop
keep going
bladesmiths you're probably wondering
why there's five of you and only four
anvils that's because one of you will be
eliminated before we even fire up the
first forge
up first is our qualifying test
ben
bladesmiths in this sudden elimination
round i'll be smashing your knives into
these blocks of ice 10 times
steve you're up first are you ready
let's do it
it's w-2 that had to be a chopper so i
tried to design for that got some weight
up front that'll hopefully carry it
through here
i think my blade will destroy that ice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
well steve
we have a problem
on the tenth strike the knife broke
that's because if you look closely at
this blade you'll see that there's a
brown section of the crack
the brown section was an old crack that
happened probably in the quench
it's been there a while it's actually
rusted
the rest of the edge is still pretty
sharp
but at the end of the day
it did break
steve that's what we call a catastrophic
blade failure and you all know what that
means
but it's not over yet each of your
blades must survive all 10 ice block
chops in order to move forward
you guys will be counting to 10 like you
never have before in your life
well brian you're up next are you ready
let's do it
this is the longest blade i've ever made
i put a maple handle on it i don't think
i'm nervous at all i know that steve's
blade just broke but i know my blade's
solid
[Music]
well brian your edge held up perfectly
it's like it never even saw the ice
it's still
like the minute you brought it in
got a nice finish to it it's got a great
shape very well done thank you
matt you're up you ready i'm ready
i used a piece of w-2 i made it short
robust strong i think it feels good in
hand so i think it's going to do well
i hope
[Music]
nice
well matt
your knife held up very well
it's got a very thick edge
it's still sharp
and it's still in one piece
well done
thank you
tyler you're up you ready swing it like
you mean it
i made it all w-2 it may be the best
blade that i've ever made but i just
hope mine holds up and i make it to 10.
[Music]
well tyler this extreme curve that you
have here made it so that as i was
chopping the ice i ended up hitting my
knuckle on the ice instead of the blade
[Music]
but uh
it held up the edge is still sharp
well done thanks
joey you're up you ready let's get her
done brother
i've never made a competition chopper
before so i've seen what one looked like
and went out and did my best to recreate
it
really very nervous i'm hoping that it's
going to do the job and survive through
that chop
[Music]
well joey
your edge held up perfectly i like the
shape of it the weight of it is a great
chopper did some damage on the ice
well done thank you sir
well gentlemen i don't think that any
bladesmith is really prepared for the
ice block shock and how devastating it
can be
that being said steve because your blade
suffered a catastrophic weapons failure
i have to ask you to please leave a
forge
to get eliminated before getting to work
in the forge
is really really disappointing
but hopefully this is just going to take
me to the next level and being a better
smith
that is a maasai lion spirit
the maasai lion spear gets its name from
an east african tribe of fearsome
warrior nomads that date their origins
back to the 15th century traditionally
used to hunt lions the weapon features a
double-edged blade at one end and a
fearsome spike with the other this
allows a messiah warrior to engage his
opponent in close quarters or at a
distance
while today lion hunts have been
replaced the deadly spear lives on in
popular culture and can even be spotted
in the film laura croft tomb raider the
cradle of life to see how lethal your
weapon is i will take your spear and
deliver lethal blows on this big carcass
matt you're up first are you ready
ready as i'll ever be let's do this
what i'm most worried about is lateral
force on this spear because it's a very
thin sleek spear
[Music]
[Music]
well
that sucks
matt i'm not gonna sugarcoat it this is
bad
your weapon has suffered a catastrophic
failure and cannot continue with testing
however john we can't just declare you
the forged and fire champion your blade
has to hold up for at least a stab and a
slash on this carcass doug
[Music]
i don't know what to say i don't know
what to think
i've never been more you know nervous in
high life
i'm hoping and praying that he doesn't
break in the same spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bladesmiths as their design these tests
push your weapons to the limit
john your blade survived the two cuts on
our carcass
matt that means unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut i have to ask you
to please leave the forge
congrats man i'm happy for you
i'm disappointed given what i know now i
would have gone back and really tried
chopping some things very hard with the
spear and hopefully broken the handle
myself
i'm really happy for john maybe i'm not
happy to lose to john but i'm glad john
won
john congratulations you built a weapon
that held up in our test that makes you
our new forged and fire champion who
also receives a check for 10 grand
[Music]
how do you feel right now uh i feel like
a million bucks but i guess 10 grand
will do all right well come on over here
and shake our answer good job but thank
you very good i want to have to uh talk
to my wife about what i'm allowed to to
do with this prize money i know one
thing my baby girl's gonna get in a
little new wardrobe
bladesmiths welcome to our first ever
dual strength test
first one to do is take your weapons
but put the edges on those big
industrial nuts
and whale down on them with a baton
then i'm going to take the tips put them
on that sheet steel and then i'm going
to baton those pommels that you threaded
onto your weapons
see how well they hold up
bill
you ready
yes sir
i hope my blade stays in one piece
especially when he's striking on that
nut
and this is all building up the anxiety
oh come on
[Music]
uh
[Music]
good job man
good job
all right bill we got a couple issues
here overall your handle held up well
your threaded pummel held up to that
batoning
big issue is your blade
we're missing some pieces here first
blow on that nut it just rounded off a
bit the second two actually took bites
out of it
and when we did the sheet steel your tip
came off as well you can actually still
see it in there so it's a bit on the
brittle side but overall it's light
feels good in the hand
so nicely done thank you
chuck how you feeling
not too good we're going to do it anyhow
let's do it
after i see it bill's edge deformation
and his tip breaking off my heart's
racing if this guy's work's gonna suffer
this kind of damage what's mine gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
all i can figure is something in the
grain structure of the metal and that
certain area didn't hold up
catastrophic failure happened this is a
hell of a test
chuck your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure
only making it to the third strike
however
you're not done yet it would seem that
both you and cole's fate lie with the
strength of cole's blade now cole your
blade still has to survive the strength
test it's got to make it through at
least three licks on that nut you think
you got what it takes
well let's see what happens all right
i'm definitely nervous about how it's
going to hold up jay has a reputation of
beating the
out of all the knives he tests and you
know i'm expecting him to not hold back
on mine i'm worried about that weak part
of my spine
chuck cole we find ourselves in
interesting circumstances both of your
blades suffered catastrophic failures in
the middle of our strength test however
chuck your blade survived three strikes
and cole your blade only went for two so
with that in mind i have to ask you cole
please leave the forge
that was pretty close i really thought i
was gonna make it through proud of what
i made it broke but i think it looked
great i'm still a bladesmith and i'm
gonna keep on keeping on
the arming sword
[Music]
the army sword was the sort of choice
for medieval european knights during an
era of advanced armor when swords needed
to penetrate both armor and flesh the
blade's point has a distinctive taper
allowing pinpoint thrusts into
vulnerable areas on an enemy a central
fuller in the blade reduced its weight
making it a well-balanced and effective
one-handed weapon
wielded with a shield in the opposite
hand knights were protected as they
delivered deadly blows powerful enough
to cleave a skull into in 1429 french
troops made a heroic counter-attack at
the siege of orleon led by joan of arc
wielding the arming sword
the lethality of your arming sword i
will deliver slashes and thrust on these
bore carcasses
john you are first you ready for this
yes sir let's do this
that hide is super thick to get through
that you really need a very fine edge
and not a lot of weight behind it and i
didn't build that
all right john let's talk about your
arming sword here it's heavy
it did cut on some parts of the carcass
other parts it just bounced off
thrusting wise though it did what it was
designed for
this will kill thank you sir
all right drew you're up you ready
yes sir let's do this
when i saw john's blade hit the carcass
first few times it didn't really cut so
great so i'm worried about my sharpness
on my blade
oh nice
[Music]
all right drew
this is a very sharp blade a great
thrusting blade and i like how you put a
counter balance right here because all
the weight is nicely distributed so
where i can thrust and slash
your blade sir
you will kill
thank you good job thank you
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
one of my favorites the ice block chop
and we super sized it
what i'm gonna do is take each of your
swords i'm gonna beat them repeatedly
and viciously into this big chunk ice
it's gonna test the overall construction
of your sword as well as its edge
holding ability now what your swords do
to the ice is secondary compared to what
the ice does to your swords
and john you're up first how you feeling
buddy
nervous
well we're gonna do it anyway so yeah
hmm
[Music]
well this is very heavy very hard to
control
also
aside from having gaps in your shoulders
here you've got a pretty good bend in
the blade and that was there before i
started
not a lot of edge left but you survived
through how you feeling
i'm ready good so am i
jay's tough on blades ice is tough on
blades it doesn't matter who's swinging
on it
and i'm just praying at this point that
nothing fails
[Music]
drew this is a beautiful sword thank you
blade is still
razor sharp which is very impressive
with an ice block chop
that being said the ice block chop is
meant to be brutal it's meant to test
the overall structural integrity of your
sword from tip to pommel problem is i'm
holding your pummel in this hand
instead of this hand
so that's an issue yeah
drew
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
i'm sad that my blade failed but i feel
really good about the fact that i was
able to
make something completely outside of my
wheelhouse but none of that matters if
the bomb comes flying off if the
functionality is in there the aesthetics
really do not matter i had a ton of fun
i would do it again in a second i'm
super excited to get back to the west
coast and just get back to work chipping
away at my custom orders
john congratulations you're the next
foraging fire champion good job
thanks
you'll be receiving a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel i
didn't want to win like that but
i feel pretty good i made butter knives
in the first round i come back with a
beast of an arm and sword and now i'm
fortunate for our champion good job
brother when i get home the first thing
i'm doing is buying a press and get
right back out to the shop and forward
some more it is only driving me to do it
more
your final challenge is to forge a
marine corps officer's sword also known
as a mammal luke
since 1825 the mammaluke sword has been
awarded to u.s marines to recognize
extraordinary service
this tradition began when the rulers of
tripoli bestowed this weapon upon marine
lieutenant presley o'bannon for his
bravery during the battle of derna
the weapon itself originates from the
ottoman empire in persia with many
similarities to the persian sham sheer
featuring a thin blade shallow curve and
its signature inward curved pommel this
deadly sword was ideal for cavalry and
foot soldiers to deliver lethal slashes
and thrusts on their enemy
this blade was so dangerous legend had
it that it was nearly unbreakable and
could cut a person in two all right
marines welcome to the keel test
to find out what lethal damage your
weapon will do i'll take your weapon
deliver killing blows to this ballistics
dummy trippy up first you ready for this
get it killer
hoorah
going into this kill test man i just
hope that it performs better than the k
bar that i made
[Music]
yikes
[Music]
holy moly
all right trip first up the handle
construction it is comfortable
your edge here is sharp even cutting
through the skull no issues at all no
chipping no glinting and when you thrust
with this it penetrates and cuts all the
way out overall sir your weapon
will kill all right here raw
all right gene you're next you ready
let's do this let's do this
i'm pretty darn nervous well i know my
blade is sharp but i don't know if it's
strong enough to get through these tests
i'm really worried that at the end of
this test my sword's gonna look like a
pretzel
[Music]
[Music]
oh no it bended
[Music]
all right gene
your weapon picked up a warp right here
okay your handle coupled with blood all
over made it very slippery and hard to
hold on to because it's blocky and
smooth and i lost my grip on it that's a
very dangerous thing to happen when
you're trying to wield the weapon but
your edge is still sharp your tip is
still thrustable and more importantly
it will kill
that'll work
[Music]
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test so to test the overall
construction of your blade and see if
they're going to hold an edge i'll be
smashing into these pots
now remember this test is not about what
your swords do to those pots but those
pots do your swords trip you up you
ready ready okay
these clay pots are thick they're brutal
i mean they'll send a shock wave down
this blade
there's no telling what's going to
happen
well tripp
a few things before we get to the
obvious your handle construction very
comfortable felt really good in my hand
felt like i could do a lot with it
but
right there at the edge there's that
little brown spot
you had a micro crack on that edge yeah
so as soon as i hit that pot it cut
loose i loved it feel its shape and its
look but
obvious problem
all right tripp while i know any marine
could take that blade and still continue
to fight in this competition your blade
suffered a catastrophic failure after
one strike on that vase gene your blade
only has to survive one strike on these
pots
[Music]
the entire marine championship for
forged and fire lies on one swing and
i've got a big old warp in my blade so
it's not over yet
nice job
[Music]
gene first off you're in one piece
you picked up that bend earlier on
but you didn't pick up any more in this
test strong blade held up good job thank
you
all right tripp looks like
gene's blade held up that means that you
cannot move forward to represent the
marine corps in our next challenge
please leave the forge
super disappointed there's really no way
to tell that you have like any minor
cracks or anything like that so you just
hey you find out when you test them
that's how we found out today get it
brother gene's gonna freaking bring home
that battle of the branches marine corps
anfield he's winning it for the marine
corps
gene congratulations you've won this
competition and that means that you're
going to be moving forward into our
battle of the branches final competition
to represent the marine corps at the
marine corps anvil and that's going to
give you an opportunity to win a check
for 50 000 good job brother
holy cow i did not see this coming it's
been a fun ride up until now but now i
got to represent the marines so now it's
it's game on and it's about to get real
those other branch service members
better look out
[Music]
the chinese war sword
the chinese war sword was a traditional
weapon of china's peasant army beginning
with the qing dynasty and continuing
through the 20th century similar to the
falshin the war sword is a massive
two-handed cleaving sword that generates
a tremendous amount of swinging power
while slashing and chopping through
opponents
with a frightening reputation as an
instrument of decapitation this blade
vanquished enemies during the boxer
rebellion and later during clashes with
japanese forces in the second
sino-japanese war
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
chinese warsaw and deliver one strike on
this
ram carcass let's see how deadly they
are
bobby up first you ready for this yes
sir let's do this
my heart's just bouncing out of my chest
you've got the skin you've got the bones
you've got to hide i only get one shot
at this ram carcass
all right bobby
one and done
as much as this is very intimidating in
its look
it is crafted nicely it's got a
beautiful look to its finish
the balance is just right for a
two-handed sword a little forward heavy
but it tells you that's where the power
is your edge is sharp even cutting
through the spine and bones no issues no
glinting no rolls overall sir your
chinese war sword
will kill thank you sir
all right well your turn ready yes sir
i'm ready let's do this
doug picks up my weapon and at this
point all the nerves are out the window
i'm just excited he's walking towards
this rams carcass and i'm ready to see
it fly right through
good job buddy thank you
all right well let's talk about your
chinese war sword here first up it's a
very bulky handle it's rounded
so as you get a good grip on it you can
feel it start to spread my hands around
but the wrapping that you put around it
does allow me to get a good grip on it
so good on that and one shot one kill
over alter your weapon
it will kill
thank you sir
ooh i just felt a fighting chill must be
the strength
jay
you boys remember me yes sir yes sir
welcome to the ice block chop
this is to test not only your edge and
your heat treat but the overall
construction of your swords
now what your blades do to the ice i'm
not too concerned about i want to see
what the ice is going to do to your
blades
bobby up first how you feeling
ready to go
me too let's do it
this is not just an ice block this
thing's a glacier
hmm
great job bobby
still razor sharp no rolls no glints
nothing
everything's still tight
i mean one of the swings i was able to
split that block
so it's got good feel wow just nice job
overall thank you
okay well
how you feeling
i'm nervous but i'm excited okay i'm
just excited so
this is gonna be brutal i'm really
worried about the crack in my tang right
now
chopping through a block that big is so
tough if there are any
compromises in my blade this is where
they're gonna show their head
[Music]
well we got a problem well big problem
sir right where you did your very rough
hollow grind there's a couple dark spots
right in here
and with that thin spot right there it
was enough to allow that blade to just
snap right in half on the first swing
so did not survive but
good effort
thank you sir
well well sometimes this competition is
full of tough breaks and you've had one
on the first strike against this ice
block in our strength test
unfortunately we cannot continue testing
your blade against your opponents and
for that reason i'd like to invite you
to shake our hands shake your opponent's
hand and then please leave the force to
your right come on my friend yes sir
excellent work dude thank you brother
it's tough
having a blade break is obviously you
know it's a tremendous failure but at
the end of the day i did the best i
could with the tools i had and i'm still
proud of the piece that i put forward
this competition has given me the
inspiration to move forward and
challenge myself in new ways
bobby you are the forge and fire
champion and that's the title that comes
with the check for ten thousand dollars
good job brother
come on forward my friend
great job great work
i feel on top of the world right now
that's a great piece man i was promised
this is not just a win for me this is a
win for my family my friends the other
smiths that i teach in the forge
this goes a long ways for our whole
community
the zulu war axe
the zulu war axe is a deadly and elegant
weapon now used primarily for ceremonial
purposes by the zulu tribe in south
africa passed down from generation to
generation this weapon was effective
against enemies as well as serving as a
symbol of political power and resistance
to colonial rule featuring an elongated
arrowhead shape that swelled in the
center this razor-sharp blade provided a
way for officers to reach over their own
formations to tear down and destroy
enemy shields the current king of the
zulu nation goodwill shuelatini wields
this weapon in marches to this day
your zulu warax look quite scary but
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage they can do to find it out
i will take your weapon deliver some
chops and slashes on this more carcass
destiny up first you ready for this
let's do it let's do it
i'm feeling nervous anxious this is not
going to be an easy test i mean this
board it's got tough skin
bones but i want to see this blade chop
this boar in half
[Music]
do it
well now sir thank you
all right dustin let's talk about your
zulu war axe
it's quite surprising that something
this light with not a lot of metal can
cut deep into this bore carcass
your blade stayed true
the handle construction is all void
enough to wear even though it tapers i
have a very good feel for it
overall sir
it will kill
thank you
all right wesley your turns are you
ready yes sir let's do this
my first concern is the handle breaking
after that it's that junction between
the blade and the tang i mean it's a
weak spot anything can happen there
[Music]
[Music]
all right questions talk about your zulu
war axe here what i find interesting
here is that the design of this blade
there's a sweet spot in here with a
little bit of weight so that first swing
alone cut in very deep there are no
glints or rolls on it the handle
construction is avoid enough to where i
get a good grip and i can get a good
feel on it and more importantly sir
it will kill
thank you
blade smiths welcome to the strength
test
the ammo box chop i'm gonna test the
strength and durability of your axes by
smashing them into these ammo boxes
remember this test is all about what
those boxes do to your axes and not the
other way around dustin you're up first
you ready let's do it all right
i know i nailed my heat treat but this
test is brutal
and i just keep thinking please survive
please survive
[Music]
well dustin i've got an obvious issue
here uh
i'm looking at your grain in here it's
beautiful it's nice and velvety
tight
but
right here
there's a little dark spot which was a
crack it happened right where the join
of your tang and your blade is and that
little crack
is a stress riser and it leads to big
failure sure
all right dustin your blade has broke on
the third strike against these ammo
boxes in our strength tests now that
doesn't mean that you're out of this
competition your competitor still has to
endure the same rigors weston that means
that your blade must survive three
strikes against these ammo boxes and if
it does you'll be the new force and fire
champion taking home that check for 10
grand you guys ready for this let's do
it let's do it all right ben
all right weston how you feeling nervous
i would be too
clearly this is not an easy test and
if dustin's blade broke there's a good
chance mine will as well i'm just hoping
it can take three strikes
[Music]
good job thanks
well weston it held up nice job this is
a nice light axe a lot of fun to swing
with every swing i could feel that the
reverberation just had kind of jiggled
into my hands
it was singing really well done thank
you thank you
weston congratulations your blade held
up dustin that means that your blade
doesn't make the cut
i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands shake your competitor's hand and
then exit the forge
great job man thank you sir
i'm pretty bummed out i really wanted to
win this whole thing westin
congratulations bud thank you good job
but
this has been one of the greatest
experiences of my life this is not the
result i wanted but at the end of the
day i'm here i'm alive i'm healthy so
i'm happy
weston congratulations you made a
beautiful zulu warax and that makes you
the forest and fire champion that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars come forward and shake
our hands my friend i am the forged and
fire champion and i feel elated i came
here to prove that i could compete with
some incredibly talented smiths and i
came out on top it's been a blast
nimcha
the nimcha is a single-handed scimitar
widely used throughout north africa
this unique weapon featured a hooked
handle knuckle guard and forward
pointing quillians that were designed as
a defensive tool to catch an opponent's
blade
featuring a deep fuller on both sides
the sword was light quick and deadly on
the battlefield largely made of recycled
blades the nymcha could be forged
quickly and in large quantities and was
a crucial weapon used by the ottoman
soldiers during the great siege of
malting in 1565.
placements welcome to the kill test
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your nymphs will do so i
will take your weapon delivers some
lethal blows on this more carcass
ryan you're up first you ready for this
make some barbecue cut no right let's
try
seeing the boar carcass i'm smiling from
ear to ear
i wanted to see him kind of bore a
carcass in half with it i know it's
razor sharp
[Music]
good job
all right ryan i don't know what's a
bigger beast the boar carcass or your
nimcha right here
this is a heavy sword everything about
the weight that you have on this
allows for a very very deep cut but it's
a lot of work because of the weight it's
very forward heavy but overall
it will kill thank you all right steve
your turns are you ready yes sir let's
do this
i'm excited ryan's blade cut well so i
know i've got some competition here mine
better perform
okay
all right steve let's talk about your
nimcha right here
first up the handle construction
it's smooth it's not blocky so i like
that you have it ovoid over there and it
marries in
before i started testing
your blade had a little bit kick off to
the side
but after the test it stayed the same
your edge
with a thinner profile like that cuts
deep also it is a much
lighter sword
than your competitors i can control with
every slash overall sir your blade feels
good
it will kill thank you sir
blade smith welcome to the strength test
the pillar and pop chop to test the
strength and durability of your edge as
well as the overall construction of your
nimchas i'll be chopping into these pots
and pillars remember this test is all
about what the targets do to your blades
and not what your blades do to the
target
ryan you're up first you ready for this
tear it up all right man
i know i'm behind the eight ball right
now
i need to perform really well in the
strengthness test
hopefully i'll i'll pull back up in the
line with him and be evened up
well ryan in the strength test the edge
that you have on here took a slight roll
like i i can't
see it so much as i can feel it
the rest of it is is really wicked sharp
it's still all in one piece
nice job thank you
steve you're up next you ready for this
yes sir all right cool
i feel pretty good i think my blade cut
a little better than ryan's maybe but he
didn't have that cant and flaw in his
blade so i think i've got a blade
that'll hold up to it
[Music]
man
well steve i got a problem man
when i picked this sword up i was
excited it's nice light
got a good shape to it but looking at
your steel here
there's a really big grain in here it
really could have used more
thermocycling i'm guessing i don't know
how you uh how you heat treated this but
however you did it ended up brittle
well steve your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure during our strength
test and can no longer continue with
testing therefore i'd like to invite you
to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then please exit
the forge
congratulations
i'm disappointed my blade broke but i
didn't want to go out that way but it is
what it is
thank you i just must have got my heat
treat wrong nobody's fault but my own i
didn't win the competition but i gained
so much more than i lost here i'm all
walk away here with my head held high
and it's going to make me a better blade
smith board i've really learned a lot
ryan congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion that is a title that
comes with a check go ahead you can
smile for ten thousand dollars brother
good job
come on
good job thank you it's not how i wanted
to win this competition but you know
it is what it is
first thing i'm gonna do is hug and kiss
my wife and and love on the kids and
play with them and get right back in the
forge there's no sleep for the wicked
you